welcome back to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Loki
season 1 episode 6 the season 1 finale
for all time always this is the episode
that introduces us to the man behind the
curtain and really sets up the events
that season 2 picks up directly we are
rewatching the episodes of season 1 to
put us in the best possible mindset for
season 2 and this episode right here is
the most critical episode to rewatch as
we do that we found even more details in
Easter eggs so let's go back through it
scen by scene to figure out what he
remains true plan really is okay this
episode starts with a buttload of stuff
let's go through it all over the Marvel
Studios opening we actually hear the
music of it's been a long long time
that's Harry James and Helen Forest song
that initially played in Captain America
the Winter Soldier and then came back in
the final scene of Avengers endgame then
we get a ton of other lines and sounds
from MCU past as they jumbl together and
then mix with real world quotes all
overlapping in chaos as we are hearing
all of the timelines in the Multiverse
converging at once okay first we hear
Iron Man's
[Music]
repulser Sam Wilson as Falcon
congratulated Ant-Man during Civil War
way to go Tic Tac way to go Tic Tac hope
Van's lying to Scott and Ant-Man that's
a he
punch that's how you punch Hulk
roaring toala salute and black panther
we go down forever we go down forever
Spider-Man's we
shooter Scott meeting Falcon and Ant-Man
you wouldn't have heard of me now you
wouldn't have heard of me Natasha
talking to Coulson and Avengers let me
put you on hold let me put you on hold
Peter Quill and Guardians of the Galaxy
dance off bro dance off bro me and you
Thor in Ragnarok he's a friend from what
he's a friend from what cap versus cap
in ingame during the Time Heist I can do
this all day yeah I know I can do this
all day yeah I know I know Muir
reverting to C happen in game
[Music]
I'll younger hang Pim and Ant-Man I'll
show youy and I'll show you ferocity
Carol Danvers and Captain Marvel H
further faster baby hire further faster
baby that's right ly toos and infinity
War we have a hul we have a Hulk corg to
Loki and Ragnarok going jump on that
spaceship and get out of we're about to
jump on that ginormous spaceship you
want to come Bucky and Winter Soldier
who the hell buy who the hell is fck
quill planning in Guardians I have part
of a plan I have part of a plan Natasha
to Loki and
Avengers I got red in my ledger I'd like
to wipe it out dror strange to
Damu Mamu I've come to bargain Vision to
Ultron I was born yesterday Hulk to Loki
and Avengers pun God pun God Thor to The
Shield brute in Thor you're big for
bigger you're
big Fort bigger Fury speech and Avengers
there was an idea there was an
idea Stark knows this Hawkeye's speech
to Wanda and
Ultron you are an Avenger Loki's final
words in Infinity
War we'll never
be
God Banner's big line and Avengers my
secret cat I'm that's my secret
cat I'm always angry Hank Pim and
Ant-Man in the WASP you my
suit you sent my suit for the mayor and
cilus to Doctor Strange time is the true
enemy of us all time is the true enemy
of us all time kills everything okay
next we hear a baby crying we think time
as a this one is a crazy pull that's the
sound of baby Loki crying in the
flashback of Odin taking him as a frost
giant ward in the first Thor film okay
we pull out from our solar system and we
hear a lecture from philosopher Alan
Watts called time and the more it
changes we think of time as a one Watts
argued that time is not the past causing
events in the future but in truth a
concept we perceive from the present
similar to the nonlinear way that he who
remains perceives time okay zooming out
from the Galaxy we hear Neil Armstrong
first words when he stepped on the
moon meanwhile this mysterious ship
Soares past us this is actually the ship
of tanier ton The Collector we saw this
blue and gold ship behind Thanos and
gamor on nowhere in Avengers Infinity
War then we hear the voice of climate
activists Greta tumberg how dare they as
all of the galaxies our known universe
appears to be contained within this blue
sphere which condenses and then explodes
we may be seeing the moment of the Big
Bang which is just interesting that this
would be the moment the universe begins
because it also appears to be the moment
the universe ends in the end is the
beginning time is a flat circle next we
hear the voice of activist Malala yusf
zai my dream and then the voice of
Nelson Mandela we have fought for the
right to experience and then we hear the
music of chosi from Swan Lake that is a
story that represents the battle between
light and dark this is followed by the
song swag Sahan nahi J from the 2018
Bollywood film happy Pier by ji I'm so
sorry if I'm mispronouncing any of these
things it's sung by faridi so sen and
niab basen then we hear Nina Simon I Put
a Spell on You and we see that
everything we've been seeing has been
set inside one black hole that neighbors
another black hole that we now swoop
down into this whole concept of black
holes actually comes back in Loki season
2 as Obie warns that entering black
holes causes what's known as
spaghettification which is actually a
real Concept in theoretical physics in
which your body would be condensed into
one long strand of yourself that's
essentially what is happening to the
viewer Right Here Right Now the music
then shifts like a radio dial to
Beethoven's fear release all of this an
astronomical geography of the spatial
relationship between universes which he
who remains later describes as stacked
and in Ant-Man the was Quant Mania he
actually depicts more than one ring
stacked on top of another okay diving
into the second black hole we hear
classic Loki from episode
5 and then one planet collides into
another and then as we stretch into a
Bifrosty 2001's based Odyssey Stargate
we hear the first Liberian president
Ellen Johnson serle's 2006 speech
motivated by women throughout the world
then vision's big line from W Vision
what is grief if not love and then the
poet Maya
Angelo this is actually from her poem
with verses about her history being
Rewritten which happens to Sylvie and
Loki this episode the final things we
hear are Sylvie open your eyes and then
some Morse code beeping which might be
the 1962 Morse code message that was
beamed out to space okay finally
characters on screen Loki and Sylvie
approach the Citadel which has that same
kintsugi cracked pattern as a timekeeper
statues and ren slayer's office all of
this seems to be compiled from different
fragments of broken universes we see two
big hourglasses flanking the entrance
director Kate Heron said that in the
design of the Citadel quote I was really
inspired by this idea of this kind of
manor house like Sunset Boulevard or
gray Gardens these basically big ornate
houses but there's a loneliness to them
production designer kazra farani who
directs an episode of season 2 came up
with the idea to make it look like it
was carved from the rock of the asteroid
that it's seated upon Sylvie takes a
breath and says aren't you going to tell
me not to kick the door in which reminds
me of the impulsive players in D
campaigns who always want to kick the
door in Leroy Jenkins in into every
battle even if the party might be facing
a big bad they always have to be talked
out a bit by the other players Sylvia is
actually delaying here this is the
moment most of her life has led up to
and she's trying to wrap her head around
it but she's understandably hesitant
Loki and Sylvia enter a chamber with
these looming hooded figures that if you
look closely have clocks for faces also
behind them there is a section by The
Citadel entrance that has been caved in
or barricaded suggesting that there are
parts of the Citadel that even he who
remains doesn't revisit maybe to avoid
bad memories of the person who used to
live here with then miss minutes Pops in
to scare the [__] out of us hell she
offers them a deal similar to the deal
made to the humans of the Matrix to be
reinserted into the timeline and forget
any of this ever happened or to continue
on with their Quest Sylvia's offered the
chance to wake up with a lifetime of
happy memories Loki has an opportunity
to finally win to beat the Avengers to
kill Thanos to take the Throne of Asgard
his fear is that the question Sylvie
asked him if Aoki is destined to lose is
true but it's not just the chance to win
that appeals to him the most two lokis
in the same place both of us together on
the timeline yeah he wants to be in a
timeline with Sylvie so they turn her
down it's fiction we write our own
destiny now a sure you do good luck with
that look at the expression on M menn's
face she does the southern bless your
heart sort of thing but when she says
good luck with that she has a malevolent
little smile like she is hoping they
would turn her down she Zips over to
meet Ren Slayer who comments on her
lateness so clearly she can't be in two
places at once we are learning little
bits and pieces about M M M minut gives
rayer a file that he thinks will be more
useful and ren Slayer asks who do you
mean by he it's still not clear how much
Ren Slayer knows how much she remembers
and what her role is in all of this back
in the Citadel the camera spins
clockwise on Loki and Sylvie
disorienting us along with them as they
make their way toward this seemingly
endless hallway that totally feels like
the long hallway in The Wizard of ozs
until they arrive at this interesting
chamber it has three complete time
keeper statues but then a fourth one
that's been broken into pieces obviously
a lot of questions remain about this
fourth statue it's probably going to be
mystery answered in a future Loki
episode we also in this room see ceiling
cogs and pendulums Bells and on the
floor a depiction of the lunar cycle all
various ways of keeping time if you
think about it there's also a Latin
phrase etched on the floor Omnia Tempest
enm Seer which translates to for all
time always now long time new rockstars
viewers know how much we use geology and
how long we've been using it for but if
this is your first time hearing about
geology get ready for Blockbuster
quality skincare on a student film
budget geology is a 23 time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie ES and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiless prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you got to do is take a
quick 30second quiz right now if you use
the code new rockstars 100 geology will
give you 100% off their award-winning
skincare trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30% off
one skin hair or body products when you
add it to your trial it's truly a wild
offer one of the best they've ever given
our audience so click the link in the
description or go to geol log. i/
rockstars 100 to get started and then we
finally meet the man behind the curtain
and don't you dare try to snatch this
guy's phone this is wild the two of you
same person I mean it's a little
unnatural but wow ah yes Jonathan major
now we could be talking about their love
for one another because this is a guy
who has had mostly contentious
relationship with his variants and with
other people seeing two variants connect
this way is wild to him now in the
comics he who remains was the elderly
TVA caretaker in the Citadel at the end
of time who built the timekeepers but
here he is a variant of Kang the
Conqueror Kate Heron said that the
costume designer Christine W had the
idea to build his look from all
different eras and different places in
in fact like the pants he's wearing are
Mongolian pants and the First characters
Loki met on the show were those
Mongolians in the goby desert basically
they wanted to make it hard to place
this he remains in any particular time
but since he's home by himself all the
time yeah his clothes should also kind
of feel like pajamas or lounge wear it's
interesting here are the light in the
room casts his face in this blue hue
making him look like his blue face in
the comics and what does he eat yep an
apple hearkening back to the TVA quiz
about Thanos eating an apple it also
reminds us of the Apple that doctor
strange used as an analog to demonstrate
time slipping in the MCU and just like
Wanda did he remains breaks the fourth
wall cuz notice he looks directly at the
camera and he says this don't tell me
I'm a disappointment yeah there was a
lot of speculation at the time of
exactly who Loki and Sylvia were going
to find at the Citadel so this is kind
of a tongue-and-cheek way of addressing
the audience's expectations directly
after Sylvie tries to kill him and he
tricks her using the time twister he
laughs this guy has been here alone by
himself for multiple lifetimes so so
this is probably the most fun he has had
in a long time which would explain why
he was so happy to see them when those
elevator doors opened he finally has
someone to drink tea with mobus
surprises Ren Slayer by returning from
the void and she calls her backup but
B15 has lured the other Hunters to FDR
High School in Fremont Ohio 2018 to show
them the truth this is where Ren Slayer
came from and her office has a diploma
from the Ohio state with the name
Rebecca termin on it Rebecca termin was
an alias that Ren Slayer used in the
comics back in the early years of the
20th century when she accompanied Victor
timely in timely Wisconsin and we will
see some version of Ren Slayer in season
2 where she is in that era you can also
notice a cup full of pens on her desk
just like the one Mobius has been
curious about all season around the
school are posters for FDR as well as
Eleanor Roosevelt and there is a sign
with a quote attributed to loudu a
journey of a th000 miles begins with a
single step back in he remains office
there is a chalkboard with the first
part of the nonlinear integration
equation this is used by Quantum
theorists to try to understand and
non-commutativity AKA whether the order
of elements and a mathematical equation
are interchangeable or nonlinear he also
has a slew of books on his bookshelves
and considering how long he's been alone
he's probably read through them all a
couple hundred times concept art for the
scene included something that would have
been crazy to actually see in live
action a helmet of Iron Man on one of
these shelves which would have been a
reference to the comics when Kang kept
trophies from all the Avengers that he
killed he reveals this is all scripted
and he shows them the proof we see
Sylvia listed as variant l190 this is
similar to the transcript they were
shown when they first got into the TVA
except of Simply everything they have
said up until this point this also
includes everything they will say he
remains mocks Loki s you think you can
trust this guy don't listen to him don't
listen to him the series started with
Loki mockingly mimicking Captain America
on my way down to coordinate search and
rescue on my way down to coordinate
search and rescue but now the tables
have been completely turned mobus tells
Riner that she can't take away people's
Free Will and tries to stop her from
leaving I'm not going to let you go
please mopus even with that you're of no
danger to me Rin Slayer disarms him as
he attacks her and she could have meant
that he wasn't a danger because she's a
stronger fighter maybe she means that
even if he prunes her the void isn't a
danger because he remains will protect
her no matter what she leaves through a
Time door in search of Free Will which
is interesting for her to say
considering she just said that the only
one who gets Free Will is the one in
charge so it's kind of like she's
seeking for a way to be in charge as he
remain sits at his desk he is framed
with his head in the middle of this
spiral window behind him the Multiverse
swirling outside it the one large window
with the two smaller ones above it
almost looks like an angry face designed
to frighten anyone who sits on the other
side of that desk but also just like the
spiraling Circle imagery just as another
reminder that time is a flat circle from
he remains perspective so he monol to
Loki and Sylvia about his Origins and
the origins of the TVA he explains how a
scientist variant in the 31st Century
discovered other universes stacked on
top of his own again what Quantum Mania
borrowed that imagery from the other
variants discovered the same thing for a
while they worked together together
using their knowledge to improve other
universes but not every variant had good
intentions some of
us new worlds meant only one thing new
lands to be conquered as he talked about
how his variants turned on each other
they shipped from scientists you'll
notice to armored Warriors and the
Warriors wear the same helmet and of the
same scar on the face that Kang ends up
having in Quantum Mania we likely saw
some of the others he mentions in that
Arena at the post-edit scene of that
film he says that he created the TVA to
manage the flow of time and to prevent
any further branches and he says that he
alone tamed elith to end the multiversal
war but now but there's a bit of
hesitancy on that as we see in Loki
season 2 he didn't do it alone that he
needed rener to help
him that's the Gambit stifling order or
cataclysmic chaos now it's unclear if he
remains actually believes that those are
the only two options or if he's just
telling these two this to see what
they'll do because this is all really
been a big sales pitch from he remains
to try to set Loki and Sylvia up with
this kind of time share at the end of
time there's two options one you kill me
and destroy all this and you don't just
have one devil you have an infinite
amount or you two you two run the thing
I've gone through a lot of scenarios
trying to find the right person to take
this spot and it turns out that person
came into Jonathan major has actually
cited Willie Wonka as an inspiration for
this character and here he ends his
offer with that kind of condescending
wonka meme pose as he remains explains
his motivation he's tired and he's older
than he looks Majors shrouds himself in
his cloak and shrinks down in his seat
as the camera pulls away from him making
him look smaller and smaller and more
frail in the frame as Loki and Sylvie
consider his offer notice there is a
crack in the floor that divides them in
the frame symbolizing their dueling Once
In This Moment Sylvie came here to kill
whoever was responsible for the hell
she's been living in constantly on the
Run never safe but Loki wants to run the
TVA with the person he cares for He can
finally have both love and power they
look at each other weapons on their laps
appearing almost like a split screen
image of the same person but then he
remains demeanor
[Music]
changes we just
crossed the threshold this is a
critically important moment that Thunder
was the sound of the Sacred timeline
breaking which seems to surprise even
him maybe even the first thing that this
character has been surprised by in
hundreds of years this is the moment
that Sylvie definitely decides to kill
him the timeline is already being thrown
into chaos even before the ACT is done
that tells us that the decision has
already been made and that Sylvie is
destined to stab he remains so did she
really have free will in that moment as
he remains takes the device off his
wrist he pushes it toward them and then
says I love all this honesty feels like
a fresh start notice how he places his
hand in the frame so that it looks like
he is still wearing it that would be
contradicting his words like he still
might be in control we know from quantam
Mania that Kang is extremely good at
manipulation he has Janet fooled in the
quantum realm and would have escaped
with her help had she not accidentally
seen inside his mind into his past Loki
and sovie duel and he remains looks on
highly entertained like Palpatine
watching people fight over him as if
he's watching a little play that he is
doing both the puppets of and this is a
play that he inserts himself into every
chance that he can but maybe he was
telling the truth better hurry
timeline's already branching yeah this
is a guy who loves theatricality who
created ridiculous timekeeper puppets
and gave them his own voice even if John
the major isn't admit it it definitely
feels like he's pulling from the
character of bottom or Puck from in a
midsummer night stream and Midsummer
Night stream ends with a play within a
play so Sylvie draws first blood in this
Jewel and lookie bleeds through his
sleeve which is where he is wearing his
heart at this moment he's come a long
way but Sylvie hasn't come quite far
enough to trust him you want the throne
I told a Throne I just want you to be
okay and they kiss and in the background
he who remains actually blinks away some
tears this I believe is the most
important detail from the season 1
finale because it shows why he remains
set Loki l1130 and Sylvie l111 190 into
motion since he can never trust his Ren
Slayer he needs a multiversal Duo to
show him how to put someone else before
oneself something that I think this Kang
will never truly learn Sylvie tricks
Loki though the tables have really been
turned on him a lot lately and she kicks
him through a Time door even as he
remains is about to be killed he's still
enjoying the show
incredible and she plunges the knife
into he remains and he winks and says
just like that decapitated timekeeper
Android set at the end of episode
[Music]
4 Sylvia is so overcome by the weight of
this moment the culmination of
everything she's been working towards
that she just has to sit on the floor
and as the camera pans up from he
remains the sacred timeline splits
behind him into more branches than we
have ever seen before and we cut back to
the TVA as mb15 watch the chrona monitor
go crazy with branches overlapping and
you can see some of these regions
glowing a bright red Kevin feige
discussed the repercussions of this
event on the larger MCU and he said you
know there's always a method to the
madness even of the Multiverse and for
the marvel.com fans who know that Loki
and Sylvie did something at the end of
that series that sort of allowed all of
this to be possible he who remains is
gone and that allowed a spell to go
wrong in Spider-Man no way home which
leads to the entire Multiverse going
quite mad in in this yeah it's just a
studio head trying to get us to watch
all these movies now the TVA that Loki
returns to is not the same one he left
like Hunters are running around in a
frenzy fully activated some headed to
the Armory Loki finds mopus and B15 in
the archives and as we learn in Loki
episode 1 that the ones in the archives
talking about the 63 branches in this
unit alone are not the ones we just saw
in the Chrono monitor Bay those are in
the present these are in the past does
he want us to just let them all branch
this point how are we even going to stop
it we can't and yes again we know that
this is a past era of the TVA but we
don't know if the he they were referring
to is he remains or Kang or some other
variant we have yet to meet but they do
call him he they know that in their era
there's just one boss not three but
neither of these two recognize Loki or
even knows his name which considering
how many variants we know had to be
pruned over the years by the TVA is just
kind of odd like they should know of
some Loki and Loki realizes that
something is off and he looks up at a
massive statue of some variant of Kang
whether it's he who remains or some
other Kang and we end with this ominous
music playing over the
[Music]
credits it's a perfect ending of someone
who had this glorious purpose who
thought everyone knew his name he was
his famous great powerful Loki now he is
just a face in the crowd which is
basically how Spider-Man no way home
ended someone who was Infamous being
reduced to anonymity Where Do We Go From
Here season 2 is the answer we already
broke down episode one of season 2 they
thank you everyone for supporting it and
our breakdown of episode 2 is coming
later tonight please subscribe to new
Rockstar subscribe to the Deep dive
subscribe to the break room and support
us by grabbing some merch From Nerd rot.
shop you can follow me at EOS follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching
bye